uh I do think I'm white material but I
also think that that's gonna that's
quite subjective so I think men might
find white materials to different men is
going to be different things they might
look for different things in a wife do
you know what I mean but if you you're
asking me if I'm white material up so
yeah I think Victoria what do you think
makes you work with you
um so I think a lot of those like
feminine attributes that we spoke about
earlier so being nurturing and being
caring and allowing yourself to be led
by the right man
um yeah and I you know I want to take
care of my man I want to take care of my
home I want to take care of my family
those are all things that I want to do
and I think those are all things that
you know can fall under being good wife
material